congratulations on the movie I really
loved it I felt like it could really
relate to it obviously you've worked
with Michael and Hannah before I'm
curious what made
um you eager to work with them again and
also why Sophia felt like the perfect
person to kind of round out that Trio
well yeah I am when I made I made a
movie called person to person which
Michael was in and um we didn't know
each other at all when we made that
movie I met him for coffee and then the
next time I saw him we were on set
um and and but since that time period we
became very close and um and so I
you know we you know he's a cinephile
I'm a cinephile we share a love of
movies and we
um and we definitely just want to work
together so I I
[Music]
wrote the part specifically for him and
thought of him and developed and even
developed some of it with him
um as I went along and Hannah yeah
Hannah I've worked with a lot and I've
actually worked with Hannah more than
anybody I realized because I made some I
I've made it I mean I don't know how
many shorts I mean like just five short
films with her and she's also in a movie
that I co-wrote called the mountain
um but uh yeah I I just you know knowing
the both of them and being friends with
both of them
I could sort of see
the possibilities of them playing a
brother and a sister and that it would
end like I could trust them as actors
and they would trust me as a director
and that we would have this
um already system sort of in place that
would be very helpful for making a film
and and um being together uh creating
something
um and then we were just so I mean it
was such a great
wonderful thing how Sophia came into it
and came I mean she came to a movie very
quickly
and once the script was sent to her it
just happened very fast and um and
yeah it just seemed aligned and then
when when we all the first time we all
met in person we've done some zooms
together but when we all met in person
and Sophia was with us
yeah just it really it felt we had the
right three people and it was it felt
like they were building a they were
building something that could that would
feel like a family the right kind of
family in this movie and uh
yeah it was it was so it was like day
two of rehearsal and then definitely day
three where I realized
that though the conversation we had had
previously and then these three people
together was really making the unit that
needed to occur for the film to work
properly yeah that's incredible and I
feel like that definitely shines through
in terms of those conversations and sort
of development what kind of things did
you all talk about in terms of like I
guess developing background for the
character because I feel like there's
obviously a lot of them sort of that
baked into the characters that maybe is
not explicitly even said in the movie
yeah I mean I had written a I had
written a draft of this script that we
thought we were going to shoot
um
and it had a lot more about the
childhood about the mother and it was
but it was such it was I couldn't
believe when I read it again how full of
exposition it was and like it just felt
sort of
not good and so like Hannah Michael and
Hannah and I had a this really
incredible long conversation about the
characters and what we wanted them what
we wanted the dynamic to be like and
what the characters were sort of like
and how they wanted them to be
and we talked about a couple movies
um and uh
and uh I took that all those that
conversation those feelings and I I
completely transformed the next draft
which is like 90 different
um and that felt like the movie the
other one the other script didn't feel
like there was something clunky or
something was wrong but this new draft
it was just completely different based
on that conversation
really felt so much more alive
um but yeah I mean it you know some of
it is the like the first draft didn't
have any poker and uh Michael and I
played poker together and he's taught me
how to our conversations have really
taught me he's a better poker player
than me and he's um
he knows poker better than me I've
learned a lot about poker from him but
hooker became
one of the things that got added to this
new script that became such an essential
part of it
um
and uh yeah so it it yeah and then uh
but that that draft was really the the
movie and it didn't change much after
after that time period yeah that's
that's awesome I love knowing about sort
of the behind the scenes development I
love how all of the siblings feel so
specific and I feel like I can sort of
relate to all of them I'm curious if
there's one that you sort of feel like
you're the most like though yeah no they
are I'm yeah I know I feel like I
actually feel equal to
um
I feel equal to all of them I mean you
know
I I you know Eric is is
a little you know he's shut off and it's
harder for him to express love I think I
think especially with Rachel it's really
hard for him to express love so he has
like a he has he has his guards up and
um
and I I often have my guards up but I
also sometimes don't have my guards up
at all like Maggie does and uh I have
that kind of part of me too and then I
have Rachel part two of just sort of
like a struggle so I I don't I actually
don't I mean I do feel very close no I
feel close to all three of them I don't
even know if I just because Eric's the
main character
um
he's he's he's almost easier to analyze
for me just to understand
the what he's his feelings of like of uh
of
um
really trying to stay in control of this
what's happening and feeling sort of
powerless when he's around Rachel and
feeling more powerful when he's playing
poker and uh it's easier for me to
understand his psychology in a way so I
feel a little closer in that sort of way
but at generally those three characters
are all I actually feel equal to all of
them and maybe that's why I wrote it the
way I wrote it yeah I mean I think that
that I think I do too I feel like I see
myself in all of them which I think is a
sign of a good you know movie when you
can feel compassion and and aspects that
he can relate to with all of them
um another thing I really really liked
about this film is that it captures that
like specific language that different
families sort of speak with each other I
think for them obviously song and dance
is huge but I think humor is another
really big aspect and something I found
really interesting is how humor can
obviously be like a comfort but also
like sort of used as a weapon in a way
when Maggie and Rachel are like laughing
at you know Eric's contribution to their
bits can you talk a little bit about
like the role that humor plays in all of
these Dynamics and I think it's really
fascinating yeah I mean you you're
exactly right with the sort of the
weapon of the thing
um I mean um
there's there's a there's a moment in
the movie where he says um you used to
think I was the funniest person in the
world and that really is like you know
he I think he used to have
she used to you know because he's the
older of the siblings he has like a he
used to have like a
he used to he used to really do had
power and like um I think even in you
know in siblings like you you
can often just see your older sibling as
being funny even if you know even if
outside that world there nobody would
ever find them funny you find them to be
just extremely funny and so I think
what's happened is that you know he has
he used to be the he used to really be
the funniest person in the world to the
both of them but you know Rachel being
the middle she got past the place first
of
sort of real like finding starting to
find him less funny and I think that was
that that's where like sort of things I
think started changing for them but now
when they're now as adults it's
um
it is sort of like he's he's trying he's
trying to he's trying to do that again
and they're just not finding him funny
whatsoever he doesn't have the same the
relationships have completely changed so
it's not you it's it would be it would
it just doesn't work
um but yeah that's what does what does
end up happening is that
throughout slowly throughout the film
those characters and that world do get
weaponized and they start to and more
and more especially near the end they
use those they use those characters to
create to
to go at war with each other and
essentially I think in the near you know
near the end they're like basically
using them to just burn down the whole
entire childhood world they're just
they're sort of Killing It Off by just I
I actually by taking those childhood
characters and
putting adult language into them which
has never really happened swearing and
like going really Full Throttle in ways
that they've never done as children but
using their you know using these all
these adult arguments that they're
having that are building up that are
still unconscious but they're building
up building up and then they just use
the childhood characters to
to tell each other some kind of truth
about how they're feeling which they
can't do as an adults and they're and
they use them in this sort of warped
kind of way as a as inside of still sort
of intra inside the childhood world but
as adults
well my last question for you is in
addition to like the dialogue feeling
very natural I feel like the
cinematography does that too and just
like sort of immerses us in this like
setting in town did you have any
references you looked her to in terms of
capturing that sort of visual language
in tone yeah it's sort of interesting
because I don't I mean um
we uh we tried yeah we did try to keep
it very simple and um and definitely
like a natural feeling we didn't I I'm
I remember the only movie we watched to
think about it I mean we did sorry we
watched a couple movies but the only one
I remember us watching was
this French movie I know some Morris by
Maurice p a lot but even if you look at
that movie it's hard to tell where we
went with it I think we just sort of
part of it was to just make sure
that um
that uh in terms of colors and and this
sort of thing that there was a warmth
that was accessible because I uh because
I've I do think of the movie I do think
of the movie as like sort of a love
story even though it's a very tricky
love story and it doesn't really reveal
itself as a love story on at the
beginning and it just started slowly
develops itself in that kind of way
between Eric and Rachel but like a
warmth and accessibility and then like
the with the shots and everything I I
there is sort of a uh like a Simplicity
that I sort of liked and I don't really
have like a template for that but I
I built it in that kind of way yeah
absolutely well thank you so much it was
great getting to talk to you and I just
can't wait for everyone to see the movie
oh thank you that's very nice thank you
so much thank you nice to talk